تحليق مسيراتها فوق البحر الاسود يدفع
روسيا لاتخاذ اجراءات مواجهه محضرا واشنطن
من اختبار صبر موسكو وقال انه سيتم ضمان
امن روسيا بكل الوسائل المتاحه واضاف ان
الولايات المتحده تظهر كل يوم الرغبه في
اتباع الطريق تصعيد واصفا هذا المسار
بالخطير للغايه لافتا الى تورط الولايات
المتحده بالفعل وبشكل مباشر في الصراع
باوكرانيا كما حذر المسؤول الروسي من ان
اعضاء الكونغرس الامريكيه الذين يطالبون
بتزويد كياف بذخائر العنقوديه لا يدركون
ما هي العواقب المحتمله على النيتو ويذكر
بانه في الرابع عشر من الشهر الجاري اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه فقدان مسيره
امريكيه من طراز ام كيو 9 بعد اصطدام
مقاتل روسيا بها فوق البحر الاسود
واشار المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه العميد باتريدر الى ان القوات
الامريكيه تواصل عملياتها فوق البحر
الاسود والتحليق في الاجواء الدوليه بما
يراعي القانون الدولي
فيما يتعلق بعمليتنا فوق البحر الاسود
نواصل القيام بها والتحليق في المجال
الجوي الدولي مما يتوافق مع القانون
الدولي حيثما يسمح لنا بذلك لكنني ولاسباب
امنيه تشغيليه لن اذكر التفاصيل المتعلقه
بالمسارات والمهام والجداول الزمنيه
واشياء من هذا القبيل الا اننا مستمرون في
القيام بتلك العمليات